speaking of the entertainment industry
there's someone in this room that's
going to be auditioning for his first
time for something are you George George
what do you want
so he's never been to audition before so
it's just an audition so what things
should he do to prep for an audition ah
so you go to a lot of ins no not only
that like important we just don't have
hot tution is also a mindset just a
mindset going in okay let's let's say
you're an agent right like you're a porn
agent okay I'm a new girl okay okay so
I'm in your office okay so I'm gonna
call me called Sally lips
Sally big lips okay that's my name okay
so go okay so how do I start okay Sally
big lips I don't know I'm so bad
agent little wait seriously I've never
auditioned what would you do as an agent
I I think I would just go off the vibe
but how would you give me a job how does
that work I
I mean porn it's like come on yes Bobby
she's already willing to get naked on
camera like do you really want to know
so I could if I was I really like take
off your shirt you got the job back room
casting couch you see how well you can
arch your back but some some girls work
more than others right yeah so that you
can help them with like a hook I think I
mean honestly like in porn it's it comes
down to a lot of things like your looks
number one obviously that's important
how well you can [ __ ] but also like I I
think attitude goes a long way
good energy having a smile on your face
not complaining
yeah yeah I feel like you don't
[Music]